[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa las impactantes
imágenes de la situación en afganistán
le dieron la vuelta al mundo en redes
sociales los usuarios compartieron
vídeos y fotografías que exponían la
nueva realidad de los afganos que ahora
volvían a ser gobernados por los
talibanes después de 20 años pero una
buena parte de este contenido fue
alterado o sacado de contexto por eso en
esta edición la revista digital
verificaremos los hechos empezamos
el domingo 15 de agosto los talibanes se
tomaron la capital de afganistán y con
ello volvieron a gobernar el país 20
años después de haber sido expulsados
por una coalición liderada por eeuu
su conquista provocó el mismo día que
una multitud de personas intentará salir
del país a medida que los gobiernos de
occidente evacuaban a sus connacionales
estaban movidos por el miedo ante un
eventual regreso de las violentas
prácticas que los insurgentes aplicaron
durante su régimen entre 1996 y 2001
especialmente contra las mujeres las
imágenes de lo que estaba sucediendo le
dieron la vuelta al mundo en parte
gracias a las redes sociales pero el
alto volumen de contenido también dio
origen a la desinformación
uno de los muchos ejemplos es la
siguiente imagen que se filtró en medio
de los reportes sobre personas que
corrían por la pista del aeropuerto de
kabul para subirse a los aviones en
despegue usuarios en redes sociales
dijeron que se trataba de miles de
personas entrando en masa a la terminal
aérea el vídeo fue compartido centenares
de veces pero pronto los fanáticos del
fútbol americano ayudaron a ponerle
contexto a la situación en realidad el
vídeo fue grabado en enero de 2019 y no
en kabul sino en la ciudad de arlington
texas en eeuu cuando miles de
aficionados acudieron al estadio haití
en ti para ver jugar a los dallas
cowboys aunque la imagen no corresponde
a kabul estampidas como estas si están
teniendo lugar allí por parte de quienes
huyen del talibán
como la anterior la siguiente imagen
también fue sacada de contexto para
reflejar el éxodo de los afganos que no
deja de ser una realidad en facebook y
en twitter señalan que esta multitud
estaba siendo evacuada de kabul en un
avión de la india pero la fotografía fue
publicada originalmente en la página web
de la fuerza aérea de eeuu en 2013 y
detalla como 670 personas son evacuadas
hacia la capital de filipinas tras el
paso del tifón taean que azotó las islas
de hecho twitter y facebook etiquetaron
las publicaciones como falsas o
engañosas esta imagen es muy parecida a
la publicada por el ejército de
estadounidense mientras transportaba a
unas 600 personas desde kabul al igual
que los ciudadanos de afganistán el
presidente afgano también abandonó su
país al enterarse de que los talibanes
habían llegado a kabul pero no lo hizo
de la forma en que lo sugiere este vídeo
dos portales de noticias que además
están verificados en facebook en twitter
y cuentan con cientos de miles de
seguidores reportaron que éste era el
mandatario subiéndose a un avión y
apunto de huir pero el mismo vídeo lo
podemos encontrar en el canal afgano
tolo news publicado el 14 de julio
cuando gun y partía a uzbekistán para
una visita dos días el mandatario dijo
que está refugiado en emiratos árabes
pero no se conocen imágenes del momento
en que fue trasladado allí otra
publicación mostraba la bandera del
talibán ondeando encima del palacio
presidencial de afganistán en reemplazo
de la bandera nacional pero el portal
español [__] punto es determinó que
se trata de un montaje a través de
varias herramientas en internet pudieron
encontrar una imagen que ya circulaba en
redes desde 2020 y que sería la original
pues contiene los mismos elementos las
luces los árboles la tonalidad del cielo
y hasta la misma ubicación de las nubes
uno de los temas que más ha llamado la
atención mundial es la situación de las
mujeres y niñas afganas ya que bajo el
dominio talibán de hace 20 años se les
prohibía trabajar estudiar salir solas
dejarse ver en público y hasta reír en
voz alta si no cumplían estas reglas
serán castigadas con azotes y
lapidaciones en redes sociales se dice
que estas prácticas ya se han vuelto a
aplicar pero por fortuna
algunas de estas macabras denuncias no
son reales veamos algunos ejemplos
varios usuarios han dicho que esta
imagen de tres mujeres caminando
encadenadas por su esposo es actual pero
verificadores de hecho de las agencias
reuters y afp encontraron que la imagen
se alteró para agregar la cadena
demostraron que la fotografía en
realidad se tomó en 2003 y contactaron
al fotógrafo quien dijo que no estaba
seguro si el hombre al frente de ellas
era su esposo por otro lado dos
fotografías de la reportera de la cadena
cnn en afganistán clarisa guard se
hicieron virales en una se le ve usando
ropa formal y en la otra un chador que
cubre su pelo en su intento por comparar
cómo sería afganistán de ahora en
adelante los usuarios sugirieron que
tras la toma de los talibanes la
periodista fue obligada a vestirse así
sin embargo la misma guarda claro que la
información era imprecisa porque la
primera imagen fue tomada en un recinto
privado mientras que la otra fue en la
calle reconoció que ahora cubre más su
cabeza pero que la diferencia no es tan
marcada
afganistán no es el mismo de hace 20
años según datos del banco mundial a
2017 el 11 por ciento de la población
usaba internet y aunque parezca un
número bastante bajo es un avance
gigante si se compara con el 0 0 0 5 %
de 2001 cuando los talibanes dejaron de
gobernar ahora se teme que los
insurgentes puedan usar el mundo digital
para rastrear vigilar y detener a la
población civil especialmente a
periodistas y activistas por ello varias
ong como access now y human rights first
recopilaron una serie de guías para que
los residentes locales limpien su huella
en internet esto incluye consejos para
mantener la seguridad digital eliminar
historial o minimizar el rastreo en
línea cómo protegerse de la vigilancia
que hacer ante la pérdida de un
dispositivo y cómo recuperar las cuentas
varios de estos documentos se han
traducido al dari y pashto los idiomas
oficiales de afganistán access nadó
también hizo un llamado a no compartir
las cuentas en redes sociales de
activistas y periodistas de afganistán
pues podrían estar poniendo en riesgo a
quienes quieran mantenerse en la
clandestinidad
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom